well the head of the united nations is
hopeful that he can get grains stored
for export in ukraine released to
countries in desperate need of them
secretary general antonio guterres
warning in a ministerial meeting for the
u.n that there's still a long way to go
but the discussions are continuing
food experts are warning that russia's
war in ukraine has put a critical pinch
in global food supplies
not helping is a recent u-turn by india
which had promised to export more wheat
it's the start of the summer and india
is experiencing heat waves this year
record temperatures come amid soaring
inflation and rising prices and the hot
weather is already hurting farmers
because of the heat wave our crops have
suffered due to the sudden rise in
temperature the water table has dropped
the great heat has decimated our crop
yield by half
that is why new delhi has banned wheat
exports it wants to put india's own food
security first amid frequent supply
chain disruptions and rising food prices
but the government has stopped short of
an outright ban india plans to honor
shipment agreements inked before the ban
and they will continue to export to food
deficit countries including egypt and
bangladesh but that doesn't supply much
relief for major wheat importers
on monday wheat prices soared to a
record high following the indian
government's announcement
now put yourself in the position where
in a low-income country or lower lower
middle income country where you were
let's say spending 50 of your income
or more
on food
and suddenly your got your your food got
more expensive
this is what we are seeing in many parts
of
of the world as we speak
and while neighboring countries like
bangladesh and sri lanka can continue to
count on india for now the question for
their governments and others across the
world is how they can feed their
populations if food prices continue to
rise
nahal jory is our correspondent in delhi
nehal good to see you take us behind
this u-turn india was supposed to make
its debut as a major wheat exporter what
happened well india had been on an
upward trend when it comes to wheat
exports for instance last year they were
able to export three times the amount
that they did the last year so there was
a lot of confidence around that and the
projections were that this year it would
be even larger exports and so india was
looking to expand its market
but that didn't quite happen because of
india's immense heat wave this year so
march this year was one of the hottest
and this was a sudden spike in
temperature not a gradual increase so it
destroyed a lot of crops across india
especially in states which are major
wheat producers and so some of the
farmers we've spoken to have lost half
of their yield
and what's also happened as a result of
that is that farmers are selling their
wheat to private traders who've been
able to offer a better price than the
government and so at the beginning of
may the government realized that they
had 30 percent less than what they
expected by this time
so under this ban where does all that
wheat go now does it stay in the
domestic market
it does
some of it goes as well to neighboring
countries like bangladesh and sri lanka
which india has been supplying for years
and will continue to honor that because
these contracts had already been signed
domestically
wheat is a staple food so most
households you eat it and cook it every
day
and
most of the production is going there
apart from that india also has famine
reserves which it keeps for disasters
and a lot of these famine reserves had
run dry because grains were used and
distributed during ascorbic relief
packages and so that is a deficit that
india needs to refill as well
nahal to what extent is delhi likely to
respond to outside pressure about this
decision
it seems unlikely
we have to remember that in 2005 india
saw a wheat crisis and it happened
because india miscalculated and exported
too much wheat and then they had to
spend the next several years importing
wheat from other countries and so
there's a sensitivity around this issue
both people and governments don't want
to make that mistake again
many of the experts we've spoken to who
are agricultural
policy researchers
they actually agree with the ban because
they say it is important to protect
india's internal food security and there
is a
growing sense that
that there is no need for india to look
uh good on the global front when it
might come back to bite them the next
day
all right nehal jury and delhi thank you
very much
you